bien bonjour à toutes et à tous
je voudrais au nom du mouvement
républicain dire quelques mots sur la
situation en grèce
le peuple grec s'est exprimé nous
prenons acte son vote et nous le
respectons
ce vote il faut le dire éloigne encore
un peu plus la grèce de ses partenaires
européens
une monnaie unique implique en effet une
solidarité mais surtout des règles et
une discipline commune il est évidemment
plus facile de dire non au remboursement
des dettes que de faire les efforts
nécessaires pour reconstruire son
économie et retrouver la confiance de
ses partenaires
le peuple grec n'est pas le seul peuple
d'europe
les pays qui ont conduit des réformes
souvent difficiles ont droit eux aussi
au respect de même que les créanciers de
la grèce parmi lesquelles je le rappelle
on trouve le contribuable français à
hauteur de près de 40 milliards d'euros
ils ont fait preuve d'une très grande
solidarité avec la grèce et ils ont
droit d'être traités avec respect
tout au long de son mandat je veux
rappeler que nicolas sarkozy a tout fait
pour préserver l'unité de la zone euro
et cela en étroite entente avec angela
merkel
la vérité c'est que la situation est
aujourd'hui très dangereuse
lorsqu'on se trouve dans une situation
aussi grave il est indispensable d'agir
avec sang-froid en refusant la tentation
de réagir à chaud sous le coup de
l'émotion
pendant sa campagne monsieur tsipras ce
avait promis au peuple grec qu'il ferait
le nécessaire pour parvenir à un accord
avec ses partenaires européens il est
maintenant au pied du mur
prenons le à ses propres mots c'est à
lui de convaincre ses partenaires c'est
la grèce qui a besoin de la solidarité
des partenaires européens pour éviter la
faillite et dont l' inverse
une dernière chance doit donc être
laissé au gouvernement grec pour
retrouver la place qu'elle a aujourd'hui
perdu auprès de ses partenaires
européens
mais il est parfaitement clair que sans
engagement public
précis vérifiables un accord n'aurait
aucune crédibilité et engagerait defacto
la grèce dans un processus inéluctable
de sortie de la zone euro
la priorité aujourd'hui
est de protéger la zone euro
sortie de la grèce de la zone euro
aurait des conséquences politiques et
économiques que nul ne peut aujourd'hui
prévoir notamment sur la croissance sur
le niveau des taux d'intérêt il est
irresponsable de laisser penser linverse
aux français
la situation est aujourd'hui très
sérieuse et il est plus que jamais
indispensable que les chefs d'état et
gouvernement
la zone euro se réunissent et prennent
les mesures nécessaires pour renforcer
l'unité de la zone euro vous savez que
nicolas sarkozy s'est déjà exprimé à
plusieurs reprises sur ce sujet il a
proposé la désignation d'un président
d'un gouvernement économique européen
qui assurerait la coordination de nos
politiques économiques d'un
secrétaire-général de la zone euro qui
poserait les bases d'un trésor européen
la transformation du mécanisme européen
de stabilité en un fonds monétaire
européen capable d agir avec toute
l'efficacité et l'autonomie nécessaire
dont nous avons besoin
sur tous ces sujets la france ne doit
plus tergiverser
françois hollande a trop souvent donné
l'impression de sacrifier l'entente
franco allemande pourtant indispensable
pour des considérations de politique
intérieure et de gestion de sa propre
majorité
profondément divisé dont nous notons
qu'une partie n'hésitent pas aujourd'hui
a affiché son soutien à la politique de
monsieur de six places il est temps que
les responsables français le comprennent
et prennent avec les responsables
allemands les initiatives un dispensaire
bhl pour préserver l'euro trop de temps
a été gaspillé
alors nous répondrons à vos questions
avec pierre lequiller qu'est notre
spécialiste comme vous le savez des
questions européennes dans quelques
instants je vais céder la parole à lydia
et à sébastien pour que il vous fera
saintot d'horizon de l'agenda de la
semaine
merci l'udc alors on va commencer par
donc l'agenda de la semaine puis ensuite
sébastien fera un point sur la question
des fonctionnaires et des cinquante
mille postes non pourvus donc l'agenda
lundi donc nous y sommes c'est le point
presse mardi une réunion de travail est
organisée au siège des républicains à
17h avec la fédération nationale des
travaux publics à 18h vous le bureau
politique se réunir à huis clos au siège
à 21h30 une rencontre avec de nicolas
sarkozy avec le bureau du cfcm aura lieu
à la grande mosquée de paris à
l'occasion de la rupture du jeûne
mercredi 8 juillet 10 à 10h une
conférence de presse relative à la
proposition de loi visant à supprimer
les freins au développement des
entreprises aura lieu au siège des
républicains avec eric woerth gérard
cherpion isabelle le callennec c'était
une conférence de presse qui avait été
voulue et annoncé lors de la réunion du
groupe à l'assemblée nationale à 17h la
commission exécutive se réunira et à
18h45 toujours mercredi les rendez vous
du projet l'est républicain autour du
thème et récits travailleurs détachés
coût du travail les freins au travail
prennent de multiples formes avec pascal
g président de sauvons nos entreprises
et dominique jaboulay fondateur du
collectif les duper et julien aubert
député du vaucluse voilà donc sébastien
merci nous avons appris par la voix de
la rapporteur à l'assemblée nationale
sur le budget qu'il y avait
entre mille postes de fonctionnaires non
pourvus par rapport ce qui était inscrit
dans la loi de finances pour la seule
police c'est 4300 postes de policiers
qui ne sont qui ne sont pas pourvus
c'est pas la première fois qu'on a cette
situation dans la police on l'avait vu
déjà dès 2013 où il avait été prévu au
budget +288 postes de policiers
supplémentaires et
le l'exercice s'est terminée avec moins
197 postes donc on avait un déficit de 4
185 postes de policiers par rapport à ce
qui était prévu donc nous constatons
qu'une fois de plus le gouvernement est
dans une opération de communication et
d'enfumage c'est finalement un nouveau
mensonge de françois hollande et on peut
pas dire que c'est parce qu'il ya un
manque de candidats puisque dans la
police pour les gardiens de la paix par
exemple quand on ouvre un concours pour
un poste il y a dix candidats donc c'est
une volonté du gouvernement de ne pas
pourvoir ces postes et pourtant c'est la
sécurité des français qui est en jeu et
donc cette situation nous donne les plus
grandes inquiétudes
sur ce qui va se produire
par rapport aux déclarations de manuel
valls de monsieur 15,9 sur le
renforcement des effectifs de sécurité
après les attentats donc nous demandons
au gouvernement nous demandons au
président de la république
de respecter les engagements qu'il a
pris devant les français et de respecter
les engagements que le gouvernement a
pris en faisant voter par le parlement
une loi de finances prévoyant ses
effectifs
on va à venir un peu sur les derniers
propos de cambadélis
donc comme à son habitude
monsieur cambadélis a encore fait une
sortie d'une rare médiocrité mais avec
lui en commençons à être habitués donc
sur sur la forme c'est bassesse
médiocrité je crois que monsieur
cambadélis n'a pas encore compris qu'il
était président d'un parti politique qui
était à la wii premier secrétaire d'un
parti politique qui était dont la qui
représente la majorité il a encore
l'impression d'être
dirigeant de d'une association étudiante
de gauche ou d'être encore dans un
militantisme étudiant je crois qu'il
faut qu'il prenne un peu la mesure de
ses responsabilités et le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste je pense
que ça oblige à avoir une certaine
hauteur de vue et une certaine
responsabilité dans les propos qui peut
tenir sur le fond monsieur cambadélis et
comme à son habitude
décevant et médiocre puisque parlait
nicolas sarkozy comme d'un agité du
bocal
alors qu'il évoque le problème de la
grèce c'est quelque part par l'est aussi
dans gala merkel comme d'une agités du
bocal puisqu'en gala merkel et nicolas
sarkozy ont été le couple franco
allemand qui a défendu les propositions
de l'eurozone et avait refusé en
2012 il me semble la proposition de
papandréou
est donc donc donc c'est critiquer
nicolas sarkozy sur sur ses déclarations
et sur sa position de fermeté à l'égard
de la grèce ces critiques et également
au gala merkel donc qu'ils aillent voir
françois hollande et qu'il demande à le
dire directement à un gala merkel qui
sera qui sera reçu à l'elysée
aujourd'hui voilà
en réponse à ces attaques de monsieur
cambadélis je voudrais insister sur le
fait que
pendant que mme merkel présenté sa
position devant le bundestag
en allemagne il n'y a eu aucun débat à
l'assemblée nationale sur la grèce il ya
eu quelques questions d'actualité auquel
on répond deux minutes mais on a eu
aucune information sur l'état des
négociations et aucune information bien
sûr donner au peuple par le président la
république je trouve ça en comparaison
extrêmement grave et on comprend très
bien pourquoi on comprend parce que il
ya une bonne partie du parti socialiste
et le front de gauche se souvient des
déclarations de monsieur asensi qui sont
pour un soutien total à la politique de
type race et monsieur hollande est dans
une difficulté parce que il doit essayer
de faire semblant être d'accord avec
madame merkel mais en même temps ils
ménagent le front gauche et
une partie du parti socialiste
d'ailleurs assez extraordinaire il ya
que le front de gauche et cette partie
de fondeurs du parti socialiste qui ont
été reçus à l'elysée les autres
responsables politiques de l'assemblée
nationale n'ont pas été reçus sur la
grèce c'est vous dire le fait qu' il
ménage est cette partie de son électorat
et ça influe évidemment sur la position
de la france qui était flou et qui a
donc encouragé monsieur de 6 grâce à l'
escalade
il aurait fallu qu'on ait la même
position que l'allemagne est d'ailleurs
tous les pays européens dans cette
affaire
monsieur hollande a joué le rôle de
thèse antithèse synthèse qui ne sert à
rien dans ce genre de crise on l'a vu
quand il ya eu des crises graves
sous la présidence de nicolas sarkozy
il faut y répondre avec énergie c'est ce
qu'il avait fait
sur la crise financière en réunissant
pour la première fois le conseil des
chefs d'état et de gouvernement c'est ce
qu'il avait fait sur la géorgie on ne
reste pas sur une ligne molle sur une
ligne
illisible
comme l'a fait le président landes alors
j'espère que sa position va changer je
n'y crois pas trop parce que je crois
que sa principale préoccupation c'est le
parti socialiste qui ne veut pas diviser
et je crois qu'il serait bon qu'à
l'instar de ce qui se passe en allemagne
on est quand même un débat sur ce sujet